Hi. My name's Mike Wales and
I'm the Web Development Curriculum Manager here at Udacity.
I usually create a new branch whenever I'm moving on to
a different piece of work.
Anytime I'm doing something different, I will create a new branch.
I like to think of it as context switching.
Whenever I'm switching to work on a new feature or
whether I'm going to correct a bug, I'll create a new branch at that time.
Git branches help you keep a project organized, particularly,
when you're sharing that project publicly.
You'll have your master branch, and
that would be your production quality branch that never breaks, always works.
And then you could have a development branch where active work is
taking place on your project.
Then a lot of times you'll have things like an experimental branch or
maybe some unique feature branches.
Those are things that you're working on, and
you fully expect them to break, and you want to share those with the public, but
with the understanding that this isn't production quality work just yet.
Branches are also good when not only collaborating publicly, but
their really good to collaborate with yourself.
So a lot of times, if I'm working on a feature, and then I come across a bug.
Branches allow me that ability to context switch and
get away from the work I'm doing on my feature.
Go back to where I need to be to fix the bug and
then compartmentalize that work.
Branches are really good.
Even if I get bored on working on a feature.
It gives you the ability to, okay, I want to switch and
start working on something else right now.